last week's publican debate said  Florida's junior senator Marco Rubio did  a particularly great job he's getting is  going to get a bounce from this people  credit his good looks his youth and the  fact that he's an excellent public  speaker well I'm really excited because  he's in LA today and he agreed to stop  by please welcome US Senator Marco Rubio  let's get him in here  hello there hello there senator yeah so  uh tell me you have a huge big wheel huh  that's pretty cool yes I do and I've got  big ideas about getting this country  back on track so vote for me Marco Rubio  good to see ya here he goes  [Music]  got my new boat yeah yeah you know a  Newt Gingrich hanging out Wow split  lanes in LA traffic all right  wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]